Wow, es ist extrem,
wie viele Fragen und Kommentare
es gab
zu meiner Reportage
aus dem Stadtpark -
der anscheinend grössten
offenen Drogenszene in der Schweiz.
Megacool, dass eine solche Diskussion
entstanden ist.
Einige Kommentare nehme ich hier auf,
beantworte und bespreche sie.
Nata licci sagt:
Also - ich habe versucht,
genau das nicht zu tun.
Genau nicht einfach hinzugehen
und wie im Zoo auf Record zu drücken,
sondern ... wirklich
mit den Menschen zu sprechen,
die Sache vorsichtig anzugehen
und nicht jemanden zu filmen, der
keine Lust hat, gefilmt zu werden.
Das war schwierig, denn die ersten
Tage konnte ich kaum etwas filmen,
weil sich niemand
direkt filmen lassen wollte.
Es brauchte Zeit,
Vertrauen aufzubauen,
damit ich merkte, wann der richtige
Zeitpunkt ist, jemanden zu filmen -
bzw. wann sie z.B. wegen der Drogen
abgelenkt sind.
Und damit auch sie
meine Motivation verstehen.
Dass ich eben nicht etwas
Reisserisches produzieren wollte,
sondern dass ich ihnen
den Raum geben wollte,
um aus ihrer Perspektive erzählen
zu können - das war die Idee.
Next: Manuela Signer.
Sie kommentiert etwas,
das viele kommentierten.
Absolut. Das war auch nie das Ziel.
Wir wollten ein Zeitdokument schaffen
und zeigen, was jetzt, 2021,
im Stadtgarten Chur los ist.
Man kann es nicht mit dem Letten
oder dem Platzspitz vergleichen,
das sind zwei Paar Schuhe,
andere Jahrzehnte, andere Drogen.
Aber eben: Fokus auf das Hier
und Jetzt im Stadtgarten.
Freshpink81 kommentiert:
"Sehr interessante Doku,
die mit den Vorurteilen aufräumt."
"Mich hätte das Thema Finanzierung
des Konsums interessiert."
Das ist eines von vielen Themen,
das man hätte aufgreifen können.
Bezüglich Finanzierung:
Ich habe rumgefragt im Stadtpark
und die meisten haben geantwortet,
es werde geklaut
und auch viel gebettelt in Chur.
Hoffentlich
beantwortet das deine Frage.
FeanorMorgoth fragt:
"Wie bist du auf das Thema
Stadtpark Chur gekommen?"
"Was war der Auslöser,
darüber eine DOK-Sendung zu machen?"
Also ...
Ich wohne hier,
nur ein paar Minuten entfernt.
In Graubünden war der Stadtpark in
den letzten Jahren oft in den Medien.
Deshalb war das Thema so präsent.
Man wusste: "Da ist was",
kümmerte sich aber nicht wirklich.
Irgendwann kam der richtige
Zeitpunkt, um dem nachzugehen.
Wir wollten uns dafür
ein paar Tage Zeit nehmen,
denn es ergibt keinen Sinn,
nur kurz vor Ort zu sein,
zu filmen und wieder zu gehen.
Man würde vielleicht erfahren,
welche Bäume es da gibt,
lernt so aber nicht die Geschichten
und Personen vor Ort kennen.
In den Medien wird das Thema oft
auf politischem Level besprochen -
was die Politiker denken,
was zu tun ist und was nicht.
Ich wollte auch herausfinden, was die
Personen im Stadtpark zu sagen haben.
Morbus Cithara fragt:
"Was haben die Begegnungen
in dir ausgelöst?"
"Hast du immer noch ein mulmiges
Gefühl, wenn du am Park vorbeigehst?"
Nein.
Ich habe viel weniger Vorurteile,
da ich jetzt gewisse Personen kenne.
Angst z.B. ist keine mehr da,
weil ich weiss,
dass die Personen
grundsätzlich friedlich sind.
V.a. gegenüber Personen,
die sporadisch vor Ort sind, wie ich.
Das ist auch ein Punkt:
Ich habe sehr viel gelernt.
Ich hatte zuvor noch nie Base oder
eine solche Pfeife in echt gesehen.
Bei Abhängigkeit kann man nicht
einfach Tabletten schlucken,
um gesund zu werden.
Es ist eine Krankheit,
die extrem ist und mich wirklich ...
... beeindruckt hat.
Es gab mir
eine andere Perspektive aufs Leben.
Wenn ich jetzt Geschichten höre,
habe ich mehr Kontext zum Thema.
Apropos reingehen in den Park:
Viele fragen,
ob ich das jetzt jeweils tue.
Letztens habe ich am Mittag
im Park einen Kaffee getrunken.
Ich habe es einfach mal getan.
Ich bin absolut froh,
dass ich es getan habe.
Tubak tubak fragt:
Es ist so:
Man kann nicht von heute auf morgen
einen Konsumraum hinstellen -
dieser muss finanziert werden
und man muss wissen, wie.
Es ist ein politischer Prozess.
Es dauerte ein paar Jahre,
bis die Politiker realisierten,
dass sie etwas tun müssen -
sei es die Regierung oder der Grosse
Rat, also das Bündner Parlament.
Jetzt kam es langsam ins Rollen.
Man liest immer wieder Interviews,
in denen es heisst, sie seien dran.
Dieses Jahr
passiere aber ganz sicher nichts,
sagte der Regierungsrat
in einem Interview.
Und danach - mal schauen.
Eine Frage von Alec Munnur
zur Polizei.
Nein, ich begegnete niemandem -
obwohl der Polizeiposten
der Stadtpolizei Chur
nur 50 m Luftlinie
vom Stadtpark entfernt liegt.
Im Stadtpark besprach ich
dieses Thema mit jemandem,
der auch am Letten war.
Diese Person fand, dort sei es viel
brutaler und ungemütlicher gewesen.
Das brachte aber
nicht wirklich etwas.
Ich glaube,
dass die Polizei das weiss.
Deshalb werden auch nicht ständig
Razzien durchgeführt.
Sie wissen genau, dass dies
das Problem nicht lösen würde.
Die Polizei sagte am Telefon,
dass sie wohl ab und zu eingreifen,
aber nicht zu aggressiv.
Sie seien auch dabei,
wenn es um Prävention gehe.
Sie machen also nicht nichts,
aber ...
Ich weiss nicht, vielleicht hätte man
etwas anderes erwartet.
Fritz Heini fragt: "Wie läuft das
mit jenen, die nicht von dort sind?"
"Fahren sie jeden Tag hin
oder haben sie ein Zimmer in Chur?"
Also: Ich traf im Stadtpark
Personen mit Zürcher Dialekt,
mit italienischem Akzent,
mit Ostschweizer Dialekt,
Personen aus den Bündner Tälern.
Ich glaube aber,
die meisten wohnen in Chur.
Ich habe aber nicht alle
nach ihrer Adresse gefragt.
Ich glaube nicht,
dass sie zum Stadtpark pendeln -
das ist eine seltsame Vorstellung.
T.S. kommentierte die Verpixelungen.
Ja.
Du kannst die Augen schliessen
und die Reportage schauen oder hören,
das ist auch möglich.
Mir war wichtig,
dass sich die Personen wohlfühlten,
als sie mit mir sprachen.
Ich wollte sie zu nichts zwingen.
Es ist ein heikles Thema,
speziell vor der Kamera.
Deshalb verstehe ich alle, die nur
verpixelt Stellung nehmen wollten.
Diese Abmachung haben wir
selbstverständlich respektiert.
Lello 1006 sagt:
Richtig.
Aber im Stadtpark wird v.a. gebased,
es wird also v.a. Kokain konsumiert,
und es gibt kein Kokainprogramm.
Es gab weitere tolle Kommentare.
"Als würde ein Basketballer
eine Fussballdoku machen."
"Du bist echt der grösste Snob
von allen Snobs da draussen, bravo!"
Yes.
"Ein riesen Weichei in der Szene."
Autsch.
Danke, I guess,
für diese sehr ehrlichen Kommentare.
Danke dafür, aber auch
für alle anderen Kommentare,
es gab auch
viele positive, konstruktive.
Wenn es um die Sache selbst,
also die Reportage geht,
freut mich das sehr - ohne Scheiss.
Falls ihr die Reportage nicht
gesehen habt, sondern nur dieses Q&A:
Schaut sie euch an, das wäre cool.
Kommentieren könnt ihr weiterhin,
ich werde ab und zu reinschauen.